Шановні колеги дійсно ми маємо прийняти
медійний кодекс в якому врахувати
директиви Європейської комісії щодо
аудіовізуальних послуг і Цей закон є
важливим для виконання семи пунктів
передумов для країни кандидата в члени
ЄС в той же час в цьому законопроекті є
ті норми проти яких жорстко боролися
європейська Солідарність як державницька
політична сила яка розпочала процес
формування законодавства що наближає
Україну до ЄС і Ната Я пишаюся тим що
наша команда роздержавила українські
медіа ми були тією командою хто
відмовилися від пропагандистського ут-1
я як прес-секретар президента і перше
віце-спікерка ніколи в житті не тиснула
на медіа не створювала чорні списки не
формувала цензуру А коли свого часу
пішла з телеканалу інтер через чорні
списки і процедуру і це абсолютно ганьба
що через 20 років темники медведчука
повертаються узаконені в цій сесійні
залі в закон про Раду тому що ви
створили цю проблему ви проголосували за
те що з бюджету парламенту щороку більше
500 мільйонів гривень виділяється на
канал Рада який сьогодні перетворився на
найгірше пропагандистське ТБ на таку
Рашу студентів в українському варіанті
де на першому місці офіс президента на
другому заступнику офісу президента на
третьому коти і собаки офісу президента
і там зовсім немає парламенту
законодавчі органи влади і вашої виборці
і наші запитують на щодня А де парламент
ви знаєте ганьба в тому що ми
обговорюємо європейські законопроекти А
при цьому цінність свободи слова не є
для вас цінністю тому що ніхто з вас
починаючи від старих обличчя які
виступали перед нами закінчуючи новими
обличчями які виступали перед нами
жодного разу Вони сказали про цінність
свободи слова прогань був про
відключення трьох патріотичних
проукраїнських телеканалів які сьогодні
борються за Україну так само жорстка як
солдати на фронті більше того частина
колективів Еспресо прямого і п'ятого
воює в колективах є загиблі і поранення
і ви відключили ці телеканали від ефіру
цифрового ви не допускаєте їх до
марафону і говорите що при цьому є за
євроінтеграцію і занадто Повірте будь
ласка це буде блокувати наш шлях до ЄС і
тому дуже важливо щоби та людина яка
натиснула оцей червоний рубільник
включила телеканали ми знаємо що вона
знаходиться на банковій для незалежної
держави європейської дуже важлива
незалежна нацрада незалежність не
виборюється тільки високими зарплатами
незалежно нацрада - це та яка помічає
помилки те що перетворився сьогодні
марафон те що перетворився сьогодні
канал Рада де немає соціалізму де немає
свободи слова де можна принижувати
опозицію і брехати про певні речі
абсолютно забувши про інституційність
парламенту і нацрада цього не помічає
Вибачте нас рада не помічає того що на
так званому каналі Freedom і дом
включається Так звані хорошие русские у
нас там представники заборонене опзж і
партії шарія віщают і цього помічає
надрада Хіба це незалежний орган ось про
що ми з вами маємо думати тому наша
команда виступає за наступне перше до
телеканалу рада Нам потрібно буде
повернутися там не може бути нічого
іншого Окрім роботи парламенту В усіх
демократичних країнах світу канали які
забезпечують діяльність роботи
парламенту висвітлюють її Працюють як
парламентській бюлетень розповідаючи про
роботу комітетів про роботу фракції
даючи платформу висловити позицію з тих
чи інших законів що ви за 10 місяців
перетвори Цей канал Там немає парламенту
немає жодної фракції і вашої виборці
запитують А що парламент втік А що
виправдаєте І за це проголосували ви і
вибачте будь ласка це потрібно
виправляти канал Рада має працювати
виключно як парламентській бюлетень Я
хочу щоб сьогоднішнє голосування
працювало так само на те щоби у нас
тепер щодня виходив бюлетенів в якому
буде представлено плюралізм думовці залі
позиція всіх парламентських фракцій
позиція наша по законопроектам а не
Вибачте будь ласка те не йогонебніше
абсолютно
творчість яка сьогодні відбувається на
цьому
постсовковому такому каналі які
перетворився на ут-1 Мені прикро що тиск
сьогодні здійснюється з банкової із
Міністерства цензури яке так само
цензурує сьогодні марафон і ви знаєте
міністр цензури має насправді хороший
досвід цензури він уже двічі вибачався
перед українцями за цензурою В 2004
говоримо за цензуру в 2014-му от Важливо
щоб не вибачився ще в 24-му бо До цього
все йде другий блок важливий цього
законопроекту Це дійсно закон про
необхідність прийняти позиції про
незалежну нацраду третій дуже важливо що
ми вилучили комедія четверте важливо
включити заборонені телеканали це буде
наше з вами відповідальність за
демократію за відданість свободи слова
Ну і наостанок Я хочу так само сказати
що
комітет працював дуже активно над цим
законопроектом подякувати членам нашої
команди в комітеті миколя княжицькому
Софії федині а Володимиру в'ятровичу
всім колегам які прийняли зміни до
закону враховуючи наші поправки по
мовному законодавству ми разом не
допустили того щоби в цьому законі була
порушена квотний принцип присутності
української мови це було би зрада
української мови зрада нашої армії і
зрада України дуже добре що ці
Дякую на Володимир